last night on the eve of the Alabama
election we all know there's a big
election going on in Alabama tonight and
we don't know what the results are yet
we taped the show a few hours before it
airs by the time this show airs we'll
know yeah whether or not more Turia's
but last night on the eve of the Alabama
election Roy Moore held a rally and his
wife Kayla became the focus when she
defended her husband against accusations
of anti-semitism yeah take a look at
this clip straight while they're here
one of our attorneys is a Jew
[Applause]
I don't know I feel like that didn't
help her argument yeah in any way you
know it's well it's the way that she
says do it does not sit right it sound
like when she out of her mouth that
sounds kind of like a slur yeah yeah it
when she says it that way it comes
across kind of weird that's why we've
flown Kayla more all the way here from
Alabama for a quick do-over let's give
her a chance come on over Kayla Merry
Christmas
we're saying that again okay all right
yes listen I want to give you the
benefit of the doubt I really do maybe
what you were saying last night just
came out the wrong way yes I think
that's possible yeah would you like to
try to say it again yes all I was saying
was we love all types of people and in
fact one of our lawyers is a Jew
[Applause]
[Laughter]
okay well that was worse what'd I do
wrong well you just you're hitting the
words so hard maybe if we tried a
different sentence how about just saying
happy Chanukah to Jews all over the
world
sure here goes happy Chanukah to Jews
[Music]
all over the world yeah much better
right again it's like when you get to
that word you sort of lean into it too
much how about this can you say the name
drew it sounds like Jew try it try drew
sure
drew see great that's see how easy that
was well I mean it's easy cuz I got a
nephew named drew who lives over there
in Mobile in that you know in that nice
part of town you know near all the
[Music]
that's probably the best we're gonna get
thank you for coming by
yeah thanks y'all Merry Christmas and a
Happy New Year right ever more everybody
thank you
you